a plan for this type of scenario and
there we have it um the king's pawn
opening and
we're gonna see a repeat of what we've
had in the previous games
yep so again the anti-berlin variation
of the spanish opening
that keeps maximum tension all the
pieces on the board both sides have just
castled their kings
slightly different from what nakamura
tried against magnus a couple of games
ago
this time though it's a heavy opening
theory battle
this position has been studied by both
players i've seen both players have this
position
on the board in their games with both
colors with white and black
so it's a clash of ideas here white just
bringing his rook to the center
soon we might see white expand in the
middle of the board white might push
a pawn in the center to try and gain
more space to try and kick away some of
the black pieces
magnus there he's paused he's trying to
remember
what his opening preparation says what
his coaches have told him to play there
he kicks back the white bishop the white
bishop steps back happily
retreating to a safer square i expect to
see magnus maybe
continue harassing that white bishop
maybe he'll push back
forward with the pawn it's not clear
where black wants to uh
place his pieces yet so he's going to
wait and
maybe just try to make some usefulness
okay he keeps his bishop nice and safe
very logical there yeah well
incidentally the the players were
following uh one of their games that
they played in the new and chess classic
um but uh okay they're now in totally
new territory
and uh hikaru playing a move that we've
seen quite
often we've seen magnus be very
successful with it just
picking up the corner pool moving at one
square just to cover
and control the potential mobility of
the black knight
and this is also incredibly thematic uh
magnus shifts his knight that was on the
left side and is moving it
to the right now all those knights now
are going to dance towards the right
side of the board
white's spending several moves
relocating his knight those two black
knights are going to keep the black king
nice and safe
white's knights are going to also occupy
the same squares
just to keep white's king nice and safe
and now magnus
he doesn't hang around doesn't waste any
more time he breaks
first in the center i was about to say
whoever can expand in the center first
tends to have the advantage in these
types of positions normally white is the
one to win that race white is able to
occupy the center with the spawns this
time magnus
maybe with the help of a pawn sacrifice
he is trying to challenge
uh in the middle of the board slightly
surprising that hikaru
didn't clarify the center he didn't
trade a set of points instead just
bringing the queen across one square
but that does allow a trade maybe magnus
will be tempted to
just play pawn takes pawn in the middle
of the board and try and make this pawn
structure as symmetrical
as possible it's harder to win with
symmetrical pawn structures
yeah i agree with you there david i
think that is absolutely what's going to
happen because the tension
has just gone from the center of the
board with that trade
and it's just much easier to handle and
oh well nope
wow absolutely not i'm gobsmacked that
magnus didn't seize the opportunity to
just take those pawns away from the
center of the board
and just kill half of the dynamism half
of the flexibility of white's position
suddenly okay yes he's solidified the
center as black that's very sensible you
occupy the center with your pawns
but there's so much more tension in the
position now he's he only needs to draw
magnus carson and i think taking the
pawns in the center
would have almost guaranteed him at
least a solid game
uh got him got him closer to that
desired draw okay he has solidified the
center instead what can white try to do
will white try to jump his knights
towards that right flank
i think so i mean because then that uh
adds more choice
and adds more spice to the equation
because you know should white should
black try to
capture pawns in the center well then
maybe the knight can capture
uh well nope we are not predicting the
moves here david uh
did not anticipate moving the bishop one
square
forward yeah that's very unorthodox
right totally i mean i
would be expecting the bishop to go
somewhere else but okay i think
this is all done in light of the night
hop
that is being threatened but it seems
very very very
tight in the back row look at hikaru's
pieces yeah
i mean i'm feeling claustrophobic just
looking at white pieces there in the
middle of the board
white pieces they're too bunched up
together not active at all magnus carson
that's a really nice an
important move in these types of
positions he just advances pawn one
square
taking squares away from potentially
white bishop white's knight
just preventing any active ideas and
suddenly
because black has one extra central pawn
uh right now
black is the one who will dictate when
the tension is clarified this is very
easy play by magnus carson now very
simple plans as well and he just
needs to bring us bishops yeah well
finally we saw hikaru pick
up his knight and uh well you said it
all
magnus needs to do is move the light
square bishop and it's out and
what is this move tucking the queen
i okay i mean i said his strategy should
be keeping pieces on the board at all
costs but this is going to the extreme
keeping your pieces on bad squares
keeping your piece on passive squares
white's queen yeah i mean that's not a
good piece right now
black can simply move his queen to an
active square and what's the pro what's
the problem
yeah right i mean side step slide step
with your queen and
move it to the left side with one just
to reinforce the center
i agree with you what is the plan i
don't know what the queen is
well magnus uh taking space
on the left side the queen side as we
call it and there he goes
he steps forward with the queen and look
at how
well protected black's santa is
and look how many squares he controls
this is a dream i mean i don't see how
hikaru could even think about
initiating any active operations this
has been a disastrous opening for
nakamura he's clearly come with a
strategy of keeping peace on the board
keeping boards
we're about to see the first trade uh
the first pieces leave the board the
first
set of pawns but uh yeah i mean white is
just too cramped
black has more space after black
recaptures that pawn in any way actually
you can
most likely just take it back with the
pawn but maybe magnus will get tempted
to trade some pieces first yeah he does
take back with the pawn and look at what
his pieces they're all
camped on their first three rows no
active pawn breaks no way to
explode open the center no threats
everything's defended for black
yes look at the freedom that black has
with the rooks i mean
you can do whatever he likes you can put
one rook here and look at the
look how terrible it looks with the
white pieces
i mean okay it's been very one-sided so
far but nakamura decides to finally
stake a claim
in the center allowing black's pawns
even further forward
now dropping back the white knight at
least he's okay
black now dropping back his bishop
lining up the same strategy that he used
in the previous game to win in the
previous blitz game
black's queen and black bishop on the
same diagonal again potentially gonna
threaten checkmate
white now wasting so much time with this
queen white's queen doing
nothing pretty much white's knight is
having to retreat black has the bishop
pair black has more space black has a
potential attack
this is dominance from magnus carlsen
total this is a
flawless uh display of domination
and now you can see the next move that's
going to be coming is some porn moves
like harry the age pawn is going to
start
moving and where can that black pawn is
going to advance
dislodging dislodging the white knight
in front of the white king and white's
king will have no more protection
okay the white king goes to the corner
but what's the idea black's pawn is just
gonna advance
were you gonna make a move david uh and
in time situation okay
magnus is just under two and a half
minutes not that worrying for these uh
speed demons okay black just takes his
bishop off the bottom rank connecting
the black rooks
white's queen side steps white would
love a queen trade right now
magnus should not go for it i don't
think he'll be tempted he can block that
trade
with his bishop for example he can
either just step the black queen back
one square
keep those queens on the board play for
the attack white has no counter play
white has no
active plan in the position and i'm just
going to jump in and say that the fourth
game between
fabiano caron and nayana ponyaci ended
in a draw okay so in about 14 minutes
day two we'll head into tie breaks on
the first blitz game so we do have
a lot more attention and a lot more fun
to go in today's show
david your suggestion has been played
you know
magnus is not having a queen trade and
now is simply aligning the rooks and the
big question is always
what is white going to do black doesn't
need to do anything fancy
um okay black retrieves his bishop the
whole way back
and know how he keeps the queens on the
board trading the queens would suddenly
release all the tension
white would never have to worry about
checkmate anymore now black's pieces
they're slowly starting to swarm towards
white's king's position
towards that kingside black's knight now
joining the action
also stepping out of the way of black's
pawns black's pawns are about to start
running
up the board on that right flank that's
where black has the advantage
black actually has more pawns upon
majority on that side of the board
that's where he should be playing look
at white's poor majority white has extra
pawns on the left side but what's he
doing over there
there's simply white's rooks are blocked
in white's knights are blocked in
i wouldn't be surprised if nakamura
calls it a day sometime soon because i
don't even see a move for him
this has been the one of the most
one-sided blitz games i've ever seen
between these two heavyweights
wow yeah but you never won a game by
resigning so you just got to keep going
and
trying not to lose on every move um
okay he's faced nakamura he knows it's
iconic
can you there's nothing productive to be
done overnight
move on okay so there you go hikari
finds a move
and is on the other side of the board
irrelevant to where the action is
happening
and uh magnus just seizes space um
he's coming on the chair that's how i
used to say when i was a kid
but yeah magnus just he needs giving
himself that energy look at black spawns
they are coming
the white rook trying to create some
chaos finding an open line there is a
threat
white wants to capture black's light
square bishop to undermine
black's defense of the central pawns but
that bishop can simply step back
okay instead magnus defends his central
pawn now there's no idea
or no viable idea yet of white's brook
sacrificing itself for black's bishop
white has an open line on the left side
of the board but it's irrelevant right
totally i mean i mean what is the rick
doing
the very real action is happening on the
right the white king
is about to get seriously
hunted and uh the white the black pawns
are just gonna start motoring down this
is every chess player's dream position
and uh to have it
in a must-win situation i mean look at
the bar as well plus
five for black and material it's level
on the board
there's no checkmates it's level
material that's how dominant black's
position is
and uh hicario has been forced to play
one
terrible terribly ugly move and now
magnus now has a protected past and pawn
to boot so
better pieces attack look at it yeah i'm
laughing yeah the thing is though
sometimes when you play so horrifically
you just have to smile and go well this
is not working for me
and just keep making the moves the best
thing to do is play
quickly and uh as long as you can't spot
an immediate
loss chances are there aren't any so
white's queen is attacked she has to
move she also has to keep protecting her
rook
at the bottom of the board black's queen
is on a nice diagonal but once white's
queen moves away from this attack
black's queen is going to jump into the
position give check to the white king
we're going to see it black's queen is
going to jump in no he doesn't yet same
idea but different order
exactly once white's pawn recaptures
that bishop
black's queen will jump in with check
white's pawns are disappearing the
shelter around the white king is
gone and it's going to be checkmate in a
few more moves
wow will he resign no well he's made a
move uh he's uh defending in a rather
unique way
the rook has uh managed to snake its way
from the left to the right but okay it's
it's going to be all over yeah okay the
bishop just retreats
white uh magnus keeping things simple
there were other deadlier ways of
finishing off this game but he wants to
play safety first chess he trades the
bishop
as soon as white recaptures his rook
will disappear magnus wins
oh look at that celebration from magnus
carlsen he is the winner of an
extremely tense quarter-final match